okay so let's begin so far our
last talk of the day we have uh matthias
christina who is going to tell us about
dancers
versus entanglement
but
afterwards we have the oh that's right
and afterwards you know today is not
done because we have a lot more fun
during a problem session
and the uh the problems are
out there
and on your computer that's right then
also gm has
sent you
carolyn
okay
okay but
the problems have been collected and
they've been sent to all the
participants at least in the
algebraic geometry program so
at 5 30
please come and people will present
the solutions okay
okay so thank you very much
for the organizers joe peter
and
for inviting me to give this talk at the
boot camp
and in general for organizing such a
wonderful
program
so my research field is quantum
information theory
and
there are some connections between
quantum information theory and
algebraic geometry and representation
theory
and so i would like to
tell you about those
and so my title is uh
try to be
slightly catchy
tensors
versus entanglement
entanglement being one of the key
concepts in quantum information theory
i guess i have an hour 15. if you have
any questions just interrupt
there's no point in waiting until the
end if anything is unclear
i also hope maybe joe can remind me
after sort of
35 minutes to make a break
he's supposed to but i would try i need
anyone
you can also do
okay
um
well so here's my outline um let's have
three
subjects i first want to give you
a
very quick
introduction to quantum information
theory
actually let me do a poll so who who has
a degree or studied mathematics
what and who has a degree in computer
science
and who's got a degree in physics
okay good so i got a degree in physics
so
we'll um but not in either mathematics
or confusion so
um quantum information theory sort of an
interdisciplinary field between uh
physicists and mathematicians and
and um computer scientists but also
these days engineers who helped the
physicists built
um some quantum devices and then that
so then we got this
i want to tell you specifically about
entanglement
and the last one
i call representation theory
and the quantum marginal problem this is
sort of a problem which is
kind of at the heart of the connection
between
quantum information theory and
maybe the topic of this program here
tell you later what that problem is
actually i wanted to rename it i wanted
to to call this conical coefficients
so it fits close
to think about it okay so let's get
started
with quantum information
um so in general physicists are looking
to describe the world right
until
around 1900
there was sort of a classical
description of the world war
maybe that's a thing about newton's
description of the water in general
and then around 1900 sort of something
changed and people
developed what is known as quantum
theory
and
quantum theory
is
the most successful theory actually
we've ever had
it's a it's the most precisely tested
theory of atoms and
other particles in the universe
and nowadays people are
able to manipulate
single atoms to very high precision so
the question arises
can you do sort of computation
by manipulating quantum matter
and for that
in the last decades
um sort of a very natural formalism has
arisen and i would like to tell you
about this formula so that's a formalism
um
i i'd say the formalism of quantum
information theory um it's only slightly
different from sort of the formalism of
quantum theory and i mean really it's
the same but it's sort of more in a
computer science language
so to every physical system
so there's sort of some axioms if you
want
maybe i say to a quantum physical system
whatever that is you may think of an
atom
you may think of an atom you may think
of
a proton you may think of a brain you
may think of every right everything is a
quantum system
um so to every quantum system um we
associate
a hilbert space
and we denote public space
by h
now
really in our case hilbert's base will
just be
a complex space cd
and the difference between between the
hilbert space and what we had before is
that the hilbert space is endowed with
an inner product
so the thing is inner product that's
important
and
we're just going to assume this is a
very simple case where you have a finite
dimensional complex space
so just you know the d-dimensional
vectors
and then
the state of the system
the state of the system
is given by a vector in that space
and for historic reasons i call this
vector size so the size of the wave
function
and um
yes and this psi is normalized
so two norm of this psi
square is one
or if you want if my inner product is
like that i have an inner product that's
equal to one
and then there was um
who introduced some some very handy
notation that we use these days is the
so-called to our cat notation so if a
vector is
a little bit space
we give it a
um
you know
line psi
a backslash wrangle so that's like
a code
um
around it so like a cat we call this a
cat
and you can of course make because you
have this inner product you make a duel
you can make a dual vector
and the dual vector you denote by this
and the smart thing about that notation
is that
then this of course is your if you take
another one
right this year is of course your is a
bracket so we call this guy
we call this guy here a cat
and this guy bra
and together they form a bracket
which is just your inner product
so that's
that's our setup
this has one other advantage is nice
notation and
namely that if i want to
look at if i take a vector that is or a
state that is
normalized namely has trace one
and i look at the projector onto that
vector
so just look at the orthogonal projector
onto this vector and only people would
maybe call it p psi
but
i can now write this down like that
and because
i'm
i want to be quicker than writing like
that
i will just do this
okay it's not an x in the middle it's a
wrangled angle
so
so now
you have the physical system it's in
that state but when you want to observe
some quantity of that system you have to
make some measurement on that system
and measurements are also described
there's some formalism for measurements
actually i should
these guys here that i told you about
these are called pure states let can
come to that later
maybe
then i want to describe measurements
but
i'm actually for simplicity just
describing what
so-called projective measurements
you shouldn't worry about it too much
measurements are given by
are given by a set of projectors
okay so pi is a set of projectors
um the pi are
um non-negative right and they're equal
to their square
and they sum to the identity
so the orthogonal haven't written
okay so it's set up for dogging
projectors
and now we have a so this measurement is
given by that
and now we have a rule for
right so i have the system i make the
measurement and i get some result on my
detector right so i make measurement and
then some result flashes up
and the result will be
this i
so if i perform this measurement
described in this way on my system
then
the probability
to obtain outcome i
will be given by
graphs i p i kept sign
and then after you've done this
measurement and you received outcome i
with that probability
okay maybe you know you can easily
verify that the sum of these probability
of course this is a non-negative number
so it's fine it's between zero and one
and they also sum up to identity to one
because
um because these guys sum up to identity
okay
the sub
sum of the squares is one or the sum is
one oh the sum is one so
all right let's just do it so if i sum
the probability of this that is just sum
over i
psi
p i
psi this is all linear
this is the identity so this is one okay
because the inner product is one thing
is normalized so pi isn't just with its
projection you just pick an orthogonal
basis right and then not necessarily a
basis actually um it doesn't have to be
uh it could be like incomplete like the
identity operator itself
would be a valid measurement
sorry what does it mean
but they sum to the other do they come
to their identity how could it be
incomplete
oh sorry um
they don't need to be um completely they
don't need to be complete basis but what
do you mean then some to the identity
the identity is the operator that's the
you know it's full dimension of four
right
right no but pis aren't necessarily a
rank one that's that equities saying yes
yes apis could be ranked too oh
i see
there's so obviously they need a
projection but they're not
one-dimensional projections right okay
okay
okay
okay
good but but it's a you know
yes the most interesting case
often is the one in the case where they
are uh one-dimensional but but here is
uh okay so
anyway so
let's
maybe i come to that later
if you have you you can also continue
thinking about them being
being rank one
but i would
not like to do that
before you continue what's the right
hand side of the equation
four up
from the bottom
that one up down one down that one yeah
the right hand side of that what's that
mean
yeah so we have psi of sine
pi
okay so you know
it's important we're going to do this
now so it's boot camp right so psi is a
vector in this space there
i put a cat around if it's a column
vector
right with components psi 1 side 2
up to side d
and if i write like that
what i mean is
psi one complex conjugate psi two
complex formula
psi d complex conjugate
okay that's it
are you happy
good
okay pose
ah so
right you do a measurement you get
outcome i
but then you still got your system
around that your particle's still there
see got it right
so i have this up this particle i make a
measurement that gets resolved and i
still have this particle so i have to
tell you what what state the particle is
in after i don't imagine
so the post measurement state
given
that
i received
outcome i
is
p i
psi divided by
square root of the probability
okay
how far
this is evidently some vector in
in the same filter space that we started
with so that thing lives in age
and now you can also verify you know you
can also convince yourself that the
thing is again norm one
because i divide by this probability
but of course if the outcome you know of
course i don't define this thing if the
outcome has probability zero right so
okay so that's actually why i insisted
before on
um on that i'm also happy with taking
higher rank projectors
because
then somehow
not only right if this was rank one if
this is rank one
then um
but this vector could easily be zero pi
of psi zero
sorry p i of psi could be zero
it could be zero yes so i said i only
defined this if if this probability is
non-zero let's say i mean it's
to have a well-defined quantity
right otherwise i don't need to find
post-measurement statement because the
outcome didn't occur
you know i just look at the system and
one of these i appears and i get the i
if it comes out with zero probability i
didn't get it in the first place
okay
right so if this this this pi right is
rank one
then you could write it like that
for some vector
for some vector phi
and then
p i applied on this
is proportional to
well it's actually
if i divide it by this probability
it's actually equal to five
ah so i have a note note no following
thing
um
note that the
so this is all you can learn about your
system right
this is this is entire quantum mechanics
for you here on the board
so all you can learn about the system is
that you plot right you have you have
your system in some state psi you hammer
on with this measurement
and then you um and you discover what
you know that's all you can learn about
your system this this probability this
probability distribution
the probability of what this i is
so
therefore
in principle
the phase right you see it from the
formula for the probability here
the phase in front of the psi
is unobservable
right you see that
um that if i you know when i multiply if
i'm going to multiply psi
by e to the
i tau times psi
because i have here the complex
conjugate there this e to the i tau just
disappears so the phase is unobservable
so in some sense you may say that states
of your systems
are
maybe just raised you know you you may
now also you
i just want to mention it right
so states are in some sense equivalence
classes under this but it's it's it's
good for us nevertheless not to think
about them as rays in the silver space
so to look at projective space because
we need this uh we need this inner
product the whole time
so i'm just like
slightly confused uh about this
just sort of how to think about so so
you're given
some state psi and you basically all you
get to observe are the outcomes bi of
side or uh
yeah no i i think about this way i'm not
giving this a psi i'm giving a physical
system
which is in if the psi
and
then for instance the question could be
what is psi
or you know
so if you think about it
um
yes
and so think about a classical system
right classical system with maybe two
states a zero and one
and then
you know you get you're getting this
this classical particle this classical
system and you don't know if it's in
zero one what do you do well you make a
measurement on that system and you
observe whether or not it's zero one
and here it's the same thing
so you give this system
and you make some measurement on it
and then you observe for this
excuse but if you make a measurement the
system may then no longer be in state
psi anymore that's right the post
measurement state is given by this state
right this is where do you get the pis
from
the physical oh the pis the pis are the
system
i described what you measured in the
upper right is where you built the
machine
but you built the machine and this
machine is described by the set
pi
is it also possible that the measurement
apparatus itself and there was a change
after you've deployed it
um before we discount that possibility
we discounted possibilities i mean of
course your apparatus could just burn
with something right
you didn't and just burn but
no i'm saying i should think of the pi's
as immutable mathematical quantities yes
um
good there's another rule so
i wasn't all on mechanics
because often we haven't got just one
particle but several parties
all right
so
given systems
with hilbert spaces
h a
h b
h c etc
the join system
has hilbert space
h
is equal to h8 tensor
hd tensor
hc etc
um
and of course
the states of the joint system
are states in this tensor product
hilbert space
and of course
if i give myself orthonormal basis say
for
for h a index by i um
yeah this will be my standard notation
for an orthonormal basis we call it a
computational basis
for the hilbert space
ket and then just i and then an a is a
subscript if i talk about article a
and if i talk about particle b i'm sorry
i
should put this right
okay
and of course punchline is
states are tensors
and because we do quantum information
theory and we got lots of particles so
if you think about computer science
right you don't want to talk about one
bit you talk about strings a bit
um we have this tensor product
everywhere
all right if you think about a
megabyte of i mean megabit cubits or
something then
quantum bits then you have really many
of them so therefore we do some
abbreviations here and i'm just
introducing them now so we're not going
to get any confused later
mainly first thing of course we're going
to drop the tensorboard right it's
obvious from the context
if i write this and i just drop the
tensor part
what's in there okay if i talk about
three particles
um
you know this sort of
writing this cat thing is also too long
so i will just do this
and then of course work here from the
context i'll drop this abc here
oh wow
okay it's a boot camp time for some
examples
where does this restriction on pi being
positive come from
um
well
i mean probably this just implies that
right
i'm pointing where it comes from
means why are we allowing only positive
information
probability is positive positive
positive seventy one he wishes to
interpret those
you're free to decide any theory you
like with like negative things etc um
the the point is that sort of um
uh this thing that i wrote down you that
sort of coincides with
what what what you do when you when you
like build an experiment in the lab
yes because otherwise the probability i
think the answer was correct otherwise
his probabilities here wouldn't be
wouldn't be positive
so the straightener for you means
positive seminar
oh yes i mean positive semi-definite but
yeah yeah i'm not actually sure what is
necessary
okay
but so yes so in contrast to sort of
mathematics in physics you're sort of
constrained what what you see in the lab
and what you have there so you have to
deal with that
um
okay anyway let's do some examples so
you
you get a feel for
for what this is and the example of
course is going to be super easy because
c2
um we call c2 and qubit it's a quantum
bit
all right why do we call this a cubit so
first of all
the zero would be
when you put the zero like this the cat
0 is
1 0 and f 1
0 1.
a general
quantum state
looks like alpha zero plus
theta one
um of course this i could write like
alpha beta
where alpha absolute value squared plus
b the absolute value squared is one
um
you know you may write alpha as
ah oh my god that's right
cosine theta half
and
beta s
into the i phi
sine
sine theta half
where theta goes from
zero to pi and pi
zero to two pi
then
you see that
i could describe
this i'm not very good at drawing
so apologize for that
you could
describe this as a sphere
so you can think of a cubit
as a vector on the sphere
with you know one of the angles is
theta and the other angle is phi
we call this qubit
it
is nice because up here
top vectors
that would be like
um you know up and
down right
are zero and one
and these correspond to the classical
fit
so if i have two orthogonal states zero
and one
these would correspond to a classical
bit zero and one
and qubit just has more possibilities
right that's all
a classical bit zero one why do i call
the zero one classical bit well i could
do a measurement
here is a measurement
a measurement where i have one of the
operators namely the p0 i take as the
operator 0 and the p1
right this identity minus that thing so
i'm sorry for my european one
so if you add the two you get identity
all right so now you can compute the
probability what what are the
probabilities so if you
now compute the probability of
probability of obtaining 0
that is
right just a reminder
that it's that thing
and then
um you will see that this is the same as
alpha absolutely squared
and the probability of of one is of
course theta absolute value squared and
the two add up to one now if i have a
zero right then the probability of
getting zero is just one
and if ever one probability of getting
one is one
so that that's why it's so it's a
classical bit it's sort of clear right
here it's clear what it is
the only reason why you would write
pizza
then you get the sphere
yes
visualization
and the particle is one classical point
in the
software
point
i want to have it from zero to pi of
course you could just go from zero to pi
half and then it would be um
we'll be fine too
so sorry you have to see that alpha
but you know you feel free to like
i think the half has to do with the
double cover s of of su-2 over so3 but
it's okay but it's okay
okay
good
so this is that thing
and um of course your wave function i
mean you know
it expands now in these
four terms
so
okay sorry this is the trivial but i
still want to do
yeah but you know people here excuse
they think it's sevens the whole time
then they started adding ups and then
i'm talking about 77 the whole time
um
it's good anyway so we go we go to next
topic okay next topic was
entanglement
okay
um
okay what does entanglement
well i said already before somehow that
zero and one these were the classical
states
and um likewise zero zero and zero one
and one zero and one one are sort of the
classical states of two bits
right so everything that sort of doesn't
look like zero 0
1 0 etc is in some sense quantum
but let's make this a little bit more
formal because of course i don't want to
have the definition of quantum depend on
my basis choice
my local business choice therefore
we come with this sort of very
mundane definition and maybe sounds
fancy
you thought tangling was a fancy concept
but it's not we're going to say the
state psi
in the silver space and
it's entangled
if it is not
believe it or not if it is not product
okay so if
it is not product then product means
that psi
is
it is another rank one
right
that's right if it's not a tensoring one
one important thing for
is that actually
and um that this definition depends on
the split of your elbow space into the
sensor product
yeah i don't know if one of the previous
speakers emphasized that i want to
emphasize that
also all classical states i mentioned
that before these kind of zero zero all
these kind of bit strings
they are of course products
now
integral states are
are quite important
definition looks very simple
but they're very important because in in
several areas so first of all they're
important in
in most modern quantum experiments
so it's it's surprising but
but you won't you almost won't see any
any any fancy experiment anymore as long
as
that doesn't evolve in some way
states that are entangled
so
in physics most exotic states that
people construct now in the lab they're
entangled
you know maybe
ones that have been around for some time
like superconductivity states and
topological materials again right now
very much at the forefront
now in computer science
we have in quantum computing we have
this algorithm for factoring
numbers show us algorithmic numbers
and one can show that if
the states appearing if you can
that if they wear entangled states
and if they if if a quantum if a quantum
algorithm doesn't have entangled states
or only weakly entangled states then
actually you can simulate it by a
classical computer
so that means that a quantum computer
fundamentally is
based on the notion of using entangled
states in some very very sort of deep
manner
now there's also the field of quantum
cryptography
that allows you to use entangled states
in a communication paradigm where sort
of one entangled particle is given to
one person typically called alice and
the other is given to bob
such that when they have access to these
entangled states
then they're able to
convert it into secret bits and
communicate perfect in perfect secrecy
so they actually so it's entangled
states here they circumvent somehow
shannon's theory that you can't do this
from 1940s so you actually can do it you
can communicate perfect secrecy
with the help of quantum mechanics
and maybe a last one
if you're interested in communication
paradigms for instance function
evaluation several people want to
evaluate the function faster than they
can do this
by classical communication then also
entanglement can help here and can help
speed up your problems
oh good
how much when does this finish four no
at five
let's take a break
can i have something
where do you order entangled cubans like
why you one of them yeah
why don't you go over to the physician
like you know you say they always say
okay make it you know two entangled
cubits
yeah how do you well one one way of
making them is uh you can they're sort
of special crystals you know the speedy
of crystals you can fire it you can fire
a photon on it
and then then that photon splits into
two
photons lose polarization
so the polarization of a photon can be
described by a c2
this fan this fashion
and
you can
these two photons that come out of
that they each have the c2 and they can
be entangled in
essentially in a state like that zero
zero
plus one one
which is a pretty [ __ ] product as far
as you can
actually put the normalization here
and because we're even lazier than that
we're typically right
so this there's a procedure where every
time you get this
ah now we're going to sabotage uh
no this was not this bbo crystal thing
doesn't work every time but
but you can nowadays produce them every
time yes
get some chocolate
yeah it's okay
welcome back
um
next question we are having is how
entangled is given quantum state now you
know what the
how entangled is a good quantum state
and when is the quantum state more
entangled than another one
these are the questions we want to
address
and we're going to address them
in this particular
way so first of all we're going to
you know
think about tensors in this sort of more
maybe more visual way by giving
the three particles two to three people
which you like to call ls poppy charlie
each has their
associated hilbert space
and there's some you know they're
somehow
weirdly correlated
okay
and the way we're going to do it
is
we're going to say that a state psi
is more entangled
than phi
if
psi can be transformed into phi
by
something called locc
by local operations and classical
communication
so this is
local
operations
and classical
communication
so we think about it really literally so
alice has some lab maybe here in
berkeley and then bob's got a lab down
in stanford
and
my friend charlie markers in
copenhagen maybe has also that
and they have each particle and these
particles are correlated and they're
given they have their correlation is
described by this quantum state sine
and now they want to transform psi into
another state phi
and what they can do is they can do
everything they can do in their lab
particularly they can do all these
projected measurements
and they can classically communicate
meaning they can phone each other on a
regular form
this is a nice notion of
transformation of a state because
it doesn't generate integrity
this notion someone doesn't generate
containment
in the sense that we had before so if
the state was not entangled
then
applying l o c c
doesn't entangle particles that's why we
look at this class of operations that's
why it's natural
so what does local operations um
mean actually let me um so local
operations or what is a sequence of
local operations and classical
communication
this is actually a sequence like in a
computer science protocol the sequence
of operations alice and bob can perform
in their system
and
the first let's say without also
generality ls starts first thing alice
does that's a local operation
alice can actually attach
another particle of course and affects
hwan state right
she can sort of
bring another particle into the lab why
not that's certainly something that you
can do
so you can attach local
hillwood space agent
h maybe a tilde
in a state
it has some fixed state
that she certainly can do
on her side
then what she can also do is she can
measure
right she can make a joint measurement
on her
on this joint hilbert space that she has
then she gets some outcome
measurement result i
and she can communicate that measurement
result i to bob
right alice
tells bob
measurement results
now let's focus bob's turn
all right bob you know attaches
local space right hb hb tilde maybe
and then he makes a measurement
bob measures
and note bob's measurement
can now depend on the measurement result
he got from alice
and then he measures he gets a
measurement result he tells charlie
charlie attaches local
hell with space and state in that tilde
space
he makes a measurement he gets a
measurement result he tells alice let's
make you know and the whole thing
repeats okay
so what about unitary transformations
can you do that
yeah it's somehow included here in this
formula
okay i already included it because i i
loved attaching the silver space and
making um
making general measurements i think it's
okay
oh because you only you can only measure
one of the states and this can only
measure one or two states you're saying
all right go do it now
let's take it offline there
it's not such a big
change
good point
yeah i could i could i could put them
into my formula from before with the
measurements
okay what is what is important now
is
um the following
um definition right so we say
that we managed this protocol lccc
managed to transform psi into phi if
that worked with probability one okay
so if
um
but it seems that phi is is living
somewhere else or am i because you're
attaching different vector spaces uh yes
so i think in in this sense of um
you have a term for this i always forget
what it's called what are these sort of
equivalences
but if you tell us what it was
mathematically then we might be able to
help you out
what this
procedure is
oh i told you what it's mathematically
uh
that that just says here right
so so you're allowed to start with psi
tensor okay
tensor i'm allowed to start with some
time
right
abc
then ellis comes in her first step she
attaches zero in this in this space
okay
then
she will perform a measurement
with some pi that live on a a tilde
and
that will
then transform her thing into some other
state
um
psi maybe one
that lives on a a tilde
b and c
right
then and she will get some outcome
and this this stage
this is going to be super complicated
now and this she gets more from i and
that outcome i right she gets that stage
it gets outcome i there's a classical
lamp flashing and says it's i
and then um
and she gets that with a certain
probability right yes
then she tells bob i right that is bob's
turn bob takes bob has that state
he attaches
the zeros
psi a a tilde
no no no but the the state of the whole
system sorry the state of the whole
system is described by psi a tilde
so when i say alice makes a measurement
with operators a a tilde what i mean
is that if you think of the whole system
the measurement operators for the whole
system are of the form should have said
that maybe
they have this measurement here and
their identity on the other systems
and now
bob now it's bob's turn right bob takes
that
b tilde
a new listed space attaches in zero
has that vector or he doesn't have that
vector but the total system is described
by that he is now allowed to perform a
measurement
and
his measurement operators are allowed to
act on b and b tilde
and
because he got this result i from alice
they are allowed
to depend on i
okay then he
does that
then we get a new state on a a tilde b b
tilde
and now it depends on i and j
and now it's charlie's turn right
so now bob communicates j to charlie et
cetera et cetera actually may raise it
either
and so it continues
and then the question is is at the end
so i for me it's the the ambient space
is somewhat not important so i'm happy
to
so if i'm talking about a a h a
if i'm talking about a vector
nha
i may
uh include this into some bigger space
for instance into this
you know i may view this as like living
in
you have a name for this we had a few
times during this workshop already
you know i may enlarge that space but
you could just show that that's a change
is given at the beginning say and it's
everything that alice can bring in
um some other kinds of products but
that's not different
i i want to have it separate but
maybe that's also the name which was
concise when you cannot in
it's not containing the small substance
so i started starting with a vector in
some hilbert space but i don't care if
you make that hilbert space bigger right
we had these big discussions this
morning about like finding like a
smaller space on which the thing is
supported
now i
frankly physically it's irrelevant
physically i can always attach like some
additional depth which is your tensor
production with a classical state that's
the point so you're not changing the
rank of the tensor or anything yes i'm
not changing the rank of a tensor that's
yeah
okay
so can i try to
uh resay what you just said yes so
it sounds like you're allowed to take
your tensor
and tensor with another vector
which is a one-dimensional in a
one-dimensional vector space and you're
allowed to perform some contractions
and then the border rank of the tensor
does not go up during this operation
these operations yes i mean the tensors
are locally equivalent
but then by attaching something they are
locally equal you can contract you could
measure you could make a mess oh yeah i
can make a measurement i can make a
measurement so that's the measurement
could drop the border oh yeah sure yeah
yes sure
absolutely it can drop it but you see
that's that's that that's good good
observation it can drop but it can't
increase it
my procedure can't increase it
and you already seen that if i start
with with rank one tensor rank one then
what i said before is my class
operations won't make it entangled so it
won't increase it to tensoring two or
higher but it's true but if i start with
something tensoring five it won't
increase it to six either
question in virginia's talk she
introduced this notion of restriction
is not the same i mean this is this is
kind of yes it's similar actually it's
similar but but what i'm requiring here
we're going to come to that what we're
requiring here is that we're doing um
that for all outcomes right
with lccc i'm requiring that i get 5
all with probability one at the end
so what what's the advantage of
tensoring with this zero a tilde because
i define my measurements to be
uh to be just projections
there's no advantage in doing that it's
just that i can't do it and i'm doing
physics so i'm i have to model this
so but my alice bob and charity they
actually can do this you can bring in
another particle they can do a
measurement on the whole thing well why
can't you just do a projection on a to
a subspace that's not that's not
generally enough it will will not allow
you to
it will give you a lower set of things
where you can transform to sorry
you can project to something diagonal
inside of a tensor that's not in there
yes you can you can do more more things
which is that's my hair
um
good
okay so now
what you can then of course study right
you can you can try to understand so one
of the goals of one of the goals in
quantum information series maybe to try
to understand this relation here when
which pairs can be transformed into each
other or when can you transform
scientific of course the natural thing
to to look at
is what we call entanglement monotones
this is just monotone functions so i'm
going to say e
is an locc entangled monotone
if e of psi
bigger than e5
for all psi llcc
so yeah so potentially this is any
relation on things in different spaces
that's what i was asking so yes cycled
leaves live somewhere and then
i could live somewhere else but i'm
gonna embed them in like a big enough
space so they both live there okay
and i'm also i'm always gonna you know i
can always re-embed into bigger spaces
it won't change anything so what from
physical prospecting function what is e
is a function
it's a function e is a function into you
know it's a no it's that's fine as long
as you say a function
real valued
function
and yes i mean i can of course say i'm
only comparing things on the same
dimension a little bit space and you
know
but but often they will actually look at
functions that you find on all bit
spaces
oh yeah i'm gonna
you see yeah i'm coming i'm coming
so are the observations on a tensor 18
that's somehow bigger than just those
induced from a
yeah yes the point that's why you can do
it
i could have okay alternatively i'm just
saying it and then i'm going to continue
um i'll tell you if we could i could
have defined some of my setup a little
bit differently in beginning with maxine
i chose this way because i think it's
simple
um
okay here's the example
let's look at our simplest example
and i want to get to something else too
but we'll see um
i have to bite into discussion time
um
okay good so
we're going to take this
we call it bipartite
pelvic space
and
let me first give you some examples of
so one thing i can do is i can this is a
matrix of course i can do singular value
decomposition
and i can get like some singular values
s i here
and i get some new
bases which i denote by
ei and f i and then this thing is
diagonal
okay
and this goes from from one to the rank
so very natural integral measures and
you can you can verify that maybe as an
exercise
um if you still have time after doing
all the other exercises
um
that the rank of psi or this r here
um you can verify actually this is an
antagonic monotone yeah well that's an
exercise so we actually you had already
discussed it in some of this before
um then but there are other ones that
are quite interesting
so for instance
um
if you take these sis
and you take the absolute values squared
and you call them now r not to be
confused with the random
let's communications call it a range
sign
okay that that uses a set of numbers
you can convince yourself they sum to
one and they're not negative well they
sum to one
so they
they are probability
distribution and of a probability
distribution i can point to take the
shannon entropy so if i take the shannon
entropy
of of these r's in which it's just
defined minus r i log ri
this is also an entanglement monitor
and then there are some invariants this
is also interesting so if you restrict
now the dimension to be two by two only
then
a entanglement monotone would be the
following function
which i'm sure all our invariant
dependence recognizes
very simplified
and
um so sorry because
it seems that you distinguish the basis
so is it like
so for rand we know that it doesn't
depend on the basis but
for the second thing that you do
yes
yes i defined exactly so for each side
for each side for each matrix here there
exists two basins one for
this one and one for that one
such that i can write in this form yes
absolutely right e i and f i depend on
sign
obtain them by singular value
decomposition
make a single value decomposition of
this thing you obtain unitary
your diagonal and another unitary and
one of the unitaries will transform this
eye into the eye and the other one will
transform this into the afternoon
okay now let me um and one of these
epsilons
epsilon no
what are the epsilons
um
no no no it's the um
what are those symbols
on the lower right hand corner of the
board
um i think they're just um
okay so then there should be delta r1j1
right maybe
think about it
okay let me give you a theorem
nice here and then i want to do one more
thing and then we're done
so this is a theorem by nielsen
very cool theorem
the theorem tells you that
why did you find these singular values
right four this guy has singular values
i call them r of psi so this guy is
singular values i call them r
case of tensor product of two
hilbert spaces now yes okay
sorry
then
if
this guy majorizes that kind
then this transformation is possible
so this means the partial sums are
strictly bigger right yeah the partial
sums of psi are strictly bigger than
that
for instance this relation here
immediately implies that
um
this entropy statement here
so this is the dominance order of the
singular values or what is just sorry no
no we are not talking a single value
singular is absolute value square are
these are sorry
our i's
are the uh are the singular values
square
squared of the singular value yes okay
so these are the singular values
then take the absolute value square
and call them r
singular vector is always non-negative
so you don't need absolute vectors
they are sorted here when writing that
partial order
uh yes or no or something or more yes
that means yes
you know just as they are
just as you
you know people who take them positive
they are also ordinary
so it's a major weak majorization as
it's also known in that as i guess um
should i write it down what it means
i think it just means that
ri of 5
oh i see
i from 1 to k
is
um
bigger than
let me do it like this
is smaller than
um for all k
and not to be
careful
and um i want to start with the biggest
one right so r
i is bigger than r i plus one
here we go that's a nice theorem
it's not so easy to put
it takes you know
to take another hour
okay but what i want to say is that
this is a spectacular theory
because nothing
similar is known
for
three tensor factors
okay for three qubits c2 tends to see
two tens of c2 you can still still do
something
but but there it stops
that's that's why it's amazing otherwise
it wouldn't be something
what would be a canonical reference to
see a proof of that oh there's a book um
there's a by nielsen and chuan
if you just type in nielsen and juan and
google i'm sure there's one book that
comes up
you know probably i'm completely wrong
but it reminds me of a theorem
where you
look at degeneration of matrices under
pairs
matrices on the conjugation children
normal form when you look what are these
degeneration orders and they also get
such a complete characterization where
these dominance order appear etcetera so
uh kraft's book is really the first
pages i wonder whether it's a
relationship everything looks very
similar to me so let's do it in the
bread okay let's talk about it so
okay what i want to tell you is that the
probability one right the statement here
from before um
you know it's very hard nielsen did it
for the case of two times a factor three
tens of factors out of the question okay
so we're gonna modify our question
all right
so we're gonna we're gonna do this here
we're gonna do this transformation just
as we did it
before but we're happy to say that we
transform psi into five
if
okay we're going to write slocc instead
of locc
if
the conversion that i wrote down before
happens
with probability
bigger than one okay bigger than zero
so
all right so you do this whole protocol
and every time you get all these you
know
alice gets measurement outcomes and bob
gets measurement outcomes and they all
come with like some probabilities
if at the end of
the day there is
just
the probability of having 5 is non-zero
rather than 1.
then we're going to say
psi has successfully transformed into 5
by slocc where this stands for
stochastic
okay
okay that thing is much easier because
of the following
very nice lemma
this is
due to dura vidal in sydney
namely it says step side
slocc5
if and only if
there exists
matrices
you know the matrices on h a
b are the matrices on hb
and c are the matrices
on hc
such that a tensor b
tensor c applied on 5
sides
so that's the connection
between
quantum information theory
and algebraic geometry
so i'm looking at tensors my natural
equivalence relation is the same as your
natural complex relationship
you would call this like a restriction
that's right
or if i'm yeah exactly or if i'm sort of
you know i could take the corollary and
say when can i transform psi into phi
and backwards and then i just get gl
right and i have like or sl whatever
because that now i'm i'm not i actually
don't care about the length of the
vector anymore because i things only
have to happen with probability
positives so i'm not actually caring
about what the norm of these things is
anymore does it work for more factors
than three
that works in general yes
so that's a very nice
that's a very nice lemma
and um i will bite into discussion time
because you are asking the whole time
it's cool
i'm confused because
i thought alice could apply in unity of
transformation very cute right
so
oh this is a lemma you have to look up
the paper
you know that's the paper
side transforms into it you know i asked
the question when can i transform psi
into five with soccs
and this is the answer
if and only if there exists
three matrices such that this is equal
to that so the
each
issue where you need slocc is
oh these are matrices right arbitrary
matrices not unitaries only matrices
it's really arbitrary matrices and if
you do it backwards right then if you
want if you want to have both directions
right if you want to say when can i
transform this with solution c
and when can i do it backwards
then of course you know the mn just
changes into gl ring
and i have general inner group and it's
acting in this triple factor fashion
there is an example
where the transformation is sloc
locc but not slow cc
had occ but not slo is there more
restrictions no
you can do everything
right if i can do something with
probably positive probability i mean if
i can do something probably one one is a
particular positive number okay and is
there an example that
is wrong essentially everything else oh
okay i mean
with high probability
you will you know think of a large
enough space and do something and i will
not be doing doable biology okay but i
guess so this theorem should already
tell you what happens for matrices
because
well one of them was already
characterized as a low cc which should
be uh yeah for two for two things that's
right for two things we have this nice
theorem but for three and more and i
mean that's sort of why we are here with
tensors etc for three or more that's our
interest that's why i wanted to tell you
that you know
so you can see for two factors if you
start with a full rank matrix you can
transform it to anything right but by
slocc but not by llcc
absolutely that was a good point i
should have said that
um
good so let us this paradigm is so nice
that i wanna i wanna i wanna do your you
know my good old friends i want to
tell you that we like them too so
what are your good old friends
well your good old friends are
um
is this guy for instance right
um i normalize it this guy is peter
would call the unit tensor
um
we've seen it a couple of times today
we called it the green burger or inside
your state so if you're really
okay much cooler it's much cooler it's a
green bird or more inside you say it
exhibits some very fancy notion of
non-locality and you know anyway
um
i had known before
yeah but when it comes better it gets
better not let's see okay let's see if
let's see how how far uh and maybe peter
knows that i'm including the people
already know the answer to the following
question you're not allowed to stop the
answer okay
but the people who see this for the
first time
are welcome so i'm giving you this state
i i get alice two qubits okay
elsa has a cubit here
so a two-dimensional space tensor
two-dimensional space charlie has
two-dimensional space tensor
two-dimensional space
bob has two-dimensional space i'm gonna
write down um
um you know
they have here they have zero zero plus
one one they have here zero zero plus
one one and here there's also state zero
zero plus one one
okay do you know this guy
ever see
no
no idea
okay
it's a two by two matrix multiplication
tensor
okay i love this one so this is actually
the two by two this is your exercise
right that's your homework show that
this guy here is a 2x2 matrix
multiplication sensor
um so one of the very fundamental this
is very easy to produce in the lab right
you just um
just as i said before you just take this
crystal you fire a photon on it you get
two photons out and you know alice does
it right
alice takes one in photon sends one to
bob and keeps one herself then she's
gonna do another
pair of particles and sends one here and
charlie is gonna do this here so they
have this quantum state which is
actually the matrix multiplication
tensor this is more difficult to produce
so
we may ask natural questions
namely
you know
can i
transform let me let me you know let me
denote this guy by that
and this guy right there so these have
two cubits
yes they each have to cube it so it's a
c4
so
c4 tensor c4 tensor c4
um okay so
i can for instance ask
can i transform the ghz state into the
matrix multiplication sensor
with slcc natural question to ask
but the gh z is in c2 tensor c2 tensor
c2 right
that's right but i could for instance
enlarge the space
or i could i could
produce it many times right
so for instance i can produce it end
times
or m times right
and i can ask you i'd like to have n of
these
of these actually we call this state
here you will you will not believe it
doesn't see famous einstein podolski
wasn't fair
okay so
this is a so-called epr here
um
fine to play where you know consider
this guy one guy right so so you can you
can ask this very natural question how
many how many ghz states do i need to
get like this triple einstein goodwill's
ocean pair thing and then i can look at
the limit as
n divided by
now m divided by n maybe
for large n right
do you know what that is
it's
either an asymptotic
so
right so the the conversion rate of
a um
so if you know
if you take if you start with this data
this sort of your a rank two state right
tensor rank two state you can produce
you know
all tensor rank two states here by so c
so if i give you like a whole range of
them like if i give you
this state tensor n right then this
thing has is it is the unit tensor of
rank 2 to the n
with rank 2 to the end
i can produce any quantum state or any
sorry any tensor with slsc with rank 2
to the end
in particular if i know if if my matrix
multiplication tensor
if m copies or sorry 2 to the m if n
copies of the matrix multiplication
tends to have rank 2 to the m then i can
produce them from here by l occ
that's why
i get the matrix multiplication at this
point
good maybe enough delta is the ghcc
yeah delta wasn't changing so i tried to
do it okay i just wanted to have some
more
um
fancy notation that you know these like
long written out tensors like i
can't do it
um
goods
so
um
well i think that's it
because um
what else do i want to tell you i want
to tell you about the quantity
coefficient now we can't do this now i
think it's still
so fine so thanks a lot
all right so there's still more time
left for questions so other questions
another question maybe it's a ridiculous
question but nielsen's theorem for more
than three factors if there's such a
theorem
uh is there any chance that it's just
that the eigenvectors of the tensor can
form that are dominated by the
eigenvectors of the tensor the other
from fine side
take the item vector tuple for psi and i
can direct those people for phi and
i i don't know what the eigenvector took
place
so this is a vector itself
well it's an element of a tensor space
and so you can compute its eigenvectors
what it's like in fact where the
argument was in tensor
it's complicated that's all you have no
maybe that's that's under the values
just for two factors
i don't know maybe
talk about later i really don't know
so for the 300 case someone worked it
out in there you know
they
they had some invariants that they
defined and
and and expressed the equivalence
relation in terms of invariance but it
got very messy
um
so maybe just to test my understanding
in the theorem by nielsen if you replace
this lock reduction by the slop
stochastic yes
then
you would get just the usual uh pencil
range
yes then it's just random just yes
that's what what joe already said before
then it's just rank right so the rank of
one just has to be bigger than the rank
of the other
so you see it gets significantly more
complicated right um when you go from uh
when you go from you know suddenly you
get like the magnitudes of these things
here
and
so it gets significantly more
complicated
any more questions
maybe one comment to painters is of
course that
you know a monotone for this slocc thing
here
right before i define the lccc
monologues we can find llc slow scheme
on the phones by functions that go down
and ls as well
they of course have things like tensor
ring bordering
you know and this uh amortized or
regularized or whatever you call it
tensor ring
yeah like omega for instance is also i
mean yeah things like that
um so you have these
uh other kind of functions they're also
some invariants which are
which are monotones
yes
so in general right so the
distinguishing you know say if i if i if
i want to look at all the things that
are equivalent so that i can transform
forward back and forth then i then i
just get into um sls lsl
orbit classification so i just want to
classify it right that's the same
problem it's just classifying
sl process and across this l orbits
and
and that you know all that sort of ties
into into this program
okay so let's not forget the homework
session which will happen in uh 15
minutes
uh
dogs